joining us with reaction as the House
Minority Leader congressman Kevin
McCarthy California congressman good to
see you thank you for being with us
let's start well let's start with Adam
Schiff because you believe that he's met
his own standard as it relates to
recusal in the investigation which
apparently the Muller investigation is
not going the way he wants well there's
a lot of questions and shift actually
laid out a couple years ago that anybody
that it shows that a conflict of
interest or disbelief and it has to
recuse themselves there's a couple
questions for shift when we were trying
to find out who paid for this dossier he
thought so we could not find out it was
the Democratic Party that paid the
Russians for the dossier then now we
find out that shift met with Glenn
Simpson who's the co-founder of fusion
GPS well who remember Nellie or worked
the wife of or over to the Justice
Department and at the time he met with
him the committee wanted to relook at
him based upon the testimony Glenn
Simpson have given so did shift talked
to Simpson about that what the committee
wanted to look at now we find out in the
Michael cone that shift talked to him we
want to know did staff meet with him did
he tamper with the witness that he tried
to direct the witness how many times did
he mean what did they say that they
talked about what issues would come up
the topics his shift has not said so
these are questions he needs to answer
the other thing that's very interesting
when Glynn Simpson came before the
committee you'd know what Adam Schiff
did at the end he asked Glynn Simpson to
direct the Committee on where they
should go with the investigation the man
who created all this then the most
outrageous thing I found in that whole
Michael Kohn hearing remember why this
whole Moeller investigation is going
forward this whole thing of collusion it
is all based upon the belief that
Michael Cohen went to Prague to meet
with the Russians Michael Cohen said he
did not so the foundation for why we are
even in the investigation the first
place has been thrown apart what did you
think congressman what did you think of
the tape I just played now in that tape
Adam Schiff believed he was talking to a
Russian operative who had
material on Donald Trump it sounded to
me an awful lot like on tape him
colluding with the Russians to dig up
dirt on Donald Trump maybe I heard it
wrong but that's what I heard I'm
wondering what you heard well remember
what else we know about Adam Schiff
before this investigation even began he
said he had proof and evidence now I'm
not related to Joe McCarthy but Adam
Schiff is a modern-day Joe McCarthy
somebody who claims something and never
has delivered but the one thing he has
delivered on protecting Fuzion GPS he
didn't want us to know that they the
Democrats paid for the Russians to have
this false dossier he protected Glynn
and met with him when others did not
know and did he tell him that the
committee was concerned about testimony
they're going to use eight up to eight
House committees now non-stop
investigation this is you know the
widest net investigation we've ever seen
this is your right this is a this is
like modern-day McCarthyism and they're
doing it to get their power back in the
hopes that we can eliminate gas oil cows
planes cars as we know them and
everything is going to be free and
confiscate pretty much everything
everybody makes I've never seen it like
this before
I don't know what the right strategy is
but if this is an abuse of their power
it should be they're doing it for a
couple of different reasons
if you watched congressman Nadler this
weekend I was on George Stephanopoulos
show with him right afterwards he is
starting to denounce the Moller
investigation why because they know
there's no collusion so they're saying
we don't have to worry about that we
need to start our own and just throwing
mud anywhere they go but we've got to
stop calling them the Democratic Party
because I've never seen it this
poisonous this toxic and there's no
other way to say it than a socialist
they want to take over your health care
they just they just introduced you can't
Medicare for all well you can't have
private health insurance they want to
take over your homes and what you can
even have in your homes are your plane's
by this new Green Deal they even call
themselves the Democratic Socialist
Party we need to call them for exactly
what this is and they want to hide from
the fact of the success of this
president just last week look what the
GDP said 2.6 percent growth when
everybody thought it was 2.2 percent
president is sitting in Vietnam trying
to denuclearize North Korea and never in
the history of this country it always
was before that the politics ends at the
water's edge if this president or any
president is overseas you would not do
to this president what they did the
dislike for this president is so great
they'll go against their own country's
safety and freedom if you would have
given 150 billion dollars in cash in
other currencies they probably would
have praised them just like they praise
that that Iranian deal mr. minority
leader congressman McCarthy thank you